hey everyone we are now sitting down
with David Saltzman from Sur analytics
and you guys are identifying biomarkers
and then teach us more because there's
some RNA is very interesting how does
that how does that relate to DNA and
then what exactly are you guys do right
that's a great question so when you
think about what biomarkers are they are
molecules within our body that we're
using to try and tell us about something
usually disease or disease state so that
we have a couple things to choose from
we have DNA we have regular RNA there
are proteins there's macromolecules and
then there's small RNAs
so whoa that's already a lot so what
we've learned over time is that small
rnas are actually better classifiers of
all the different tissues in our body
than any of those other types of
biomarkers so we can use them to do
things like diagnose cancer and do
things like detect diseases at their
very earliest stages because you can
find apparently expressed small RNA is
in the bloodstream and because we can
map them back to a certain tissue that
they came from we can actually know what
type of tissue is being affected so they
can they can replace imaging they can
replace things like MRIs whoa okay
so then am i taking your proprietary
drug to find this in my body and then
how are you identifying it no we don't
have anything to do with drugs so how do
you identify the biomarker right so from
a sample and that sample can be tissues
stool or stool or any type of fluid
sample like blood or cerebrospinal fluid
we extract out all the small rnas and
then we do sequencing ok so there's a
difference between regular RNA and
smaller yep that's right
so regular rnase make proteins encode
for about two percent of our genome and
small RNA is actually function as little
molecular traffic lights turning on and
off the expression of those big RNAs oh
okay so then oh that's how then if
you're identifying the small RNA which
turns on or off the regular RNA
then which does the protein expression
yep so that way then you know by
identifying the small RNA whether or not
something is starting to cause a disease
in the body yep that's correct
yeah Eureka okay so so either through
blood or through any tissue it can be a
tissue biopsies all of the cells in our
body make small RNAs and the smaller
nays are actually what's required for
making and maintaining all of the
tissues so they are what make your brain
your brain it's what makes your heart
your heart your liver your liver and
your kidney your kidneys but then do we
need to pull from how would the red
blood cell and my blood how would that
how would the small RNA there tell you
about potentially some sort of chester
or pelvic right so we're using small
rnas
to diagnose things like dementia and we
know that when diseases originate in the
brain the brain will actually secrete
small rnas out into the rest of the body
and we can find them in a blood in the
blood and because we know that they've
they've originated in the brain we can
use them as indicators for things that
are happening when there's really no
other way to see what's going on in your
brain the number one user knows also
hours yeah and actually all types of
dementia right so dementia is a blanket
term that's used to describe a number of
different diseases that at the very
earliest presentation look identical to
a doctor so being able to tell the
difference between Parkinson's and
Alzheimer's and vascular dementia and
progressive supranuclear palsy and other
all of these other types of rarer types
of dementia that right now cannot be
classified until a patient has followed
longitudinally for about like four years
of time there's no way to do that so
small RNAs hold the potential to do that
because we know that the underlying
biology that's creating those different
diseases can be detected in the
bloodstream because again we can map
these smaller rnase back to the
underlying biology that's affecting the
cells so walk us through how dementia is
occurring and how that's changing
small RNA right so dementia is a disease
is a disease of the neurons but every
type of dementia has a different
underlying biology right Alzheimer's
different from Parkinson's which is
different from Huntington's disease and
because of that we would find unique
signatures for each type of disease in
the blood okay and and then and then as
an example how would Alzheimer's or
Huntington's or Parkinson's affect small
RNA well because because the neurons are
sick and they're sick in a very
particular biology there's a certain
biological pathway that's altered okay
and because of that that leads to
altered small RNAs okay okay so the
pathways that I need not to be
identified fat yep that's what we're
that's what exactly what we do okay so
we identified the smaller Nasik and
classify those different diseases okay
got it got it and then them that's the
main ones is the neurological diseases
for now yep well that's that is where I
certainly see the biggest need yeah so
you know things like cancer you can take
a biopsy and you can look at that biopsy
seven ways from Sunday
right and I don't particularly see the
need for new biomarkers in cancer right
maybe things like early detection where
you could use small RNAs to you know
detect cancer mm-hmm before you could
before a patient gets sick or before you
can see it via imaging but yeah I seen
or I see neurological diseases as being
the critical need in the space for
additional biomarkers and then maybe
teach us about exactly where you guys
are at in the company are you guys
already having people submit their blood
sample to you right so we've tested over
160 patient samples already through our
academic collaborator and we're in talks
with a number of pharmaceutical
companies right now who want to
incorporate our biomarkers into their
drug development programs okay great so
then you can even potentially just give
the biomarker identification technology
to pharmaceutical companies as oh yep
that is one aspect of our business model
we can certainly license our technology
however right now we're planning
building all of our biomarker tests in
house and then selling them to to drug
developers on a per sample basis on a
per sample base yes okay cool so that
way we're we you you would then be a
company that sells your biomarker tests
to different companies from some
companies that's your main platform then
yep that's correct
hopefully for neurological and more yep
that's correct so imagine that your
imagine your company making a job for
Alzheimer's disease number one you want
to be able to make sure that that the
patients that are coming into your trial
actually have that disease and not
something else that looks like
Alzheimer's right so these patients
would never respond to the drugs that
you've developed and those types of
people would get tested once at baseline
and you could say yes come in or nope we
don't want you you're actually a
candidate for a different type of
clinical trial or we could do things
like test pharmacodynamics where we
would be testing a patient before and
after treatment and seeing how these
small RNA profiles change in response to
drug